would you say that there is something
you
dislike about the acting world
uh
being the lady bombs
doesn't hate me at most
um
because i really do want to get rid of
labels
but um
by saying
yes we can
do things
[Music]
how did it feel
growing up with down syndrome
well at first i
didn't did not know that i had
damn
um
but
i think i uh i feel like in the um other
um
kid it would
fail
did you have any role models when you
were growing up yes
my very own um
my brother
and the student is a role model
documentaries he's making
did you always
want to be an actor and to perform
yes
my
very first uh role
was it was
[Music]
christmas show that i
did
my career
really took off
and was on coming
down the mountain
that was my
uh very first
tv role
in which
i
worked with him
nicolas holt
and it
and it was a
90-minute
tv
drama
but two um
brothers
getting to know each other
nicholas holmes tried to
push me of a mountain
so i
decided
to get my revenge
my character
surfing
back at him
which was a quite a proud moment in my
career
what would you
say was your most exciting role
i mean it has to be
being on a line of uh
do you see
so who did you play there
jerry
boyle
thrive really well
when
a
challenging role comes up
and do a
pressure
so the
more
challenges that come away
or um
rise up against a challenge
how does it feel to be working with
celebrities
i mean it's a number one way personal
highlights in my uh career because most
of them
works with uh
kelly mcdonald
uh
vicky mcclure
the uh
treated me like uh any other
professional and
academic i also couldn't enjoy making
them
um laugh
about having a you enough
and uh talking about her films and
effort
as well
would you say that there is something
you
dislike about the acting world
uh
being a lady
hate me at most
um
because i really do want to get rid of
labels
but um
by saying
yes we can do things and then once you
send that as a
powerful message
to
anyone
who might um
want
um having it
down syndrome
is a
challenge
really
because i
i really do want other people living
down listen to him
um
be who they truly are
and um
hopefully uh carry on they're really
hard to work
every single person
do a have a gift
inside of them
and i might
um
want to
dig that's a
gift out and to resew it to the
world
assuming that the uh
truly um capable of as well
do you think
there are enough roles for people with
down syndrome i think this should be
more representation
for
people
living with a
damn
dream
to make themselves
noticed even more
but
the only
problem with that
is that um
casting
directly
and
users
and writers
should um
um
do even more
uh
to create
stories with them in
in this
what do you enjoy most in acting
i didn't really serve my
um
skills
and the talent
she would
um make people
uh
um emotions
like
laughing
crying
shouting
and swearing
all for the love of it
truly is the greatest passion in my life
what does it take to be a good actor
well
um having um
an early night
learning your lines
and uh
getting in the head
of your character
and used to uh
find out what they are
feeling
from their emotions
what is your dream role
well hopefully
um to me
[Music]
james bond
shaken
but
understood
i mean my other option
me
is to play a
character
that might um
save the
day
and make his own
presence being
failed as well
if you can say one thing to the
young
actors
what advice would you give them
well i can
keep them
believing in yourselves
and
keep on
dreaming
and uh
um carry on with all your hard work
and hopefully
um
you know
be when um i am
wherever
parliament and to him
become law
and it basically means
all people
living
down the
you can syndrome
um
live a really
healthy and happy uh
lives
to be a fool
and
me
film films
um much
better healthcare
housing
and
businesses as well
[Music]
you